you guys are building this incredible
company around like space manufacturing
and contract manufacturing etc like what
is your background even understand that
this problem exists let alone have
enough kind of confidence and courage to
work on it yeah it's a weird journey so
um i've got a mix of like blue collar
kind of logistics experience from uh
helping run e-commerce businesses in
australia and at the time this is like
pre-ebay pre-amazon and australia's a
big country so it's very like logistics
heavy to run an e-commerce thing you got
to actually run like a warehouse and
figure out a bunch of international
shipping as well so i was always
building software for uh like blue
collar environments um
and then i was uh head of sales in a
very technical environment building like
automated scheduling software for large
large factories large shift-based
workforces so if you have like 5 000
people in a logistics facility like how
do you know how many drivers you need
how many know you know how many for
forklift drivers you need all that other
stuff so building very complex software
that connects with like a real world
environment like people and machines
so i've always been in that weird blend
of like blue collar finance and um and
like building complex software
and i wanted to build something in the
american industrial base because i
realized that at a very like peter teal
style macro view you've got um
software really hasn't touched
industrials at all um you know there's
sas companies that sell to industrial
you know and you've got like sap or
whatever but you know it's all built to
sell to the cfo and get a million dollar
contract it's not actually built to
drive any real operating efficiencies so
i realized that at a macro view the only
way to bring bring technology to the
industrial spaces in general is
basically vertically integrate a
software company with an industrials
company and the value creation was in
being the most efficient factor on the
planet not in selling sas software to
other factories because you know they
only use 10 of it there's a lot of
misaligned incentives all this other
stuff
and then i think mission is really
important so
you know i was working 80 or 90 hour
weeks like we were killing it as a
business was awesome but
you know i was getting pretty burnt out
and i realized it was primarily because
um i think 90 of the venture funded
companies in the world you know you
could delete basically and outside the
investor base and the employees the
world wouldn't really blink
i think it's really yeah maybe more
maybe more yeah yeah and i think there's
a lot of contrived missions out there
right um and that's fine but i hate the
cognitive dissonance of like we've got
this really amazing mission but everyone
knows you're just trying to make money
like that's actually fine just say you
want to make money and then you know go
do that don't like hide the ball behind
some contrived mission but for me it was
like what i want to do for the next 20
years and how can i align um you know
what i've kind of landed on as like an
archimedes lever of a company which is
you build the company and the economic
incentive of building that company as
big as if possible is all completely
aligned with the mission so there's
never any like oh we're like an esg
company and we're trying to make money
and there's a clash between the balance
sheet and like what what the mission is
of the company
um
so i literally went bottoms up on the in
every basically every manufacturing
industry in america um so when i landed
here i didn't know what specific
industry and manufacturing i wanted to
build this type of company in so i
literally bottoms up analyzed you know
food paper plastics you know logistics
aerospace like every type of
manufacturing you can how do you do that
well like what's the process you say hey
i want to go learn about the paper
manufacturing like supply chain what do
you do you call like 100 people a day
okay um so the the there's a lot of
alpha in manufacturing because it's not
like you can you know download a report
or it's on zoom info or something where
like you can understand the margins of a
food manufacturing business for example
right
the knowledge is out there there's a ton
of plant managers and people experts in
the industry or whatever but it's um yes
i i literally just reached out to you
know 50 to 100 people a day from all
these different industries um and
started to learn
you know where's the technology at you
know how automated is each industry what
are the margins how fragmented supply
based like what are the macro challenges
what are the micro challenges and
started hearing the same beat in
aerospace where it was this like keith
draboy highly fragmented low nps you
know you had to vertically integrate the
solve problem for the you know type of
type of market
um and because of the boom in commercial
space there was huge changing demand
signals from the customer side you know
they're moving 10 times faster than the
legacy primes there's net news spend all
over the place and then supply chain is
really breaking and basically what i
realized was
um there's this enormous you know 40 50
billion dollar high margin market that's
being served by three to four thousand
literal mom and pop small businesses the
average revenue of a single business is
about eight to nine million dollars it's
unbelievably fragmented
and all these businesses basically got
started either around the time of the
cold war or the first space race and
basically what you've got is all these
amazing incredible you know family
operated manufacturing businesses
serving our most important companies in
space defense semiconductor
manufacturing you know ev toll
um
and it's just a period of time where the
customers are basically just moving too
fast and the supply chain domestically
that's making parts for these companies
is just not keeping up and when i
realized that and then when you realize
the geopolitical importance of the us
having strong space and defense
capability especially in this decade
when we're butting heads with china you
know the reserve currency the world
might be shifting you know either to
like a you know a kind of uh
multi-polar system or you've got like
the rise of bitcoin as well as like a
potential
pseudo reserve currency in the world so
there's all the interesting dynamics and
once you realize that there's huge
customer pain right now but also for the
country and for you know having having a
u.s led system where it's largely free
and you understand that you know none of
these important companies that are
making rockets satellites suggested
drones can operate over the next decade
and really increase their production to
the level that we need them to without
the supply base being really fixed then
it's perfect mission alignment but yeah
it was all bottoms up brute force
discovery yeah so when we look at the
aerospace uh space or industry um what's
fascinating to me is there's uh i listen
to a couple of podcasts that you did and
one of the things that you brought up
was like look
pretty much all the players were built
for like the original space race right
and
they've been around for a long time
they're usually owner uh operated
they're uh relatively small in the grand
scheme of things you know millions of
dollars to maybe low tens of millions of
dollars in revenue a small employee base
super super fragmented to your point uh
almost you know no technology in the way
that you or i would think of of kind of
technology and where it is today uh and
it kind of just feels like it's like a
good gig like like when i was listening
to you talk about it i kind of thought
of it as like oh it's the type of thing
where like you know you get done early
and like you can like go golfing with
your buddies and like it provides a good
life for you and your family and like
you're off to the races but
it's not the 90 100 120 hour you know
work week how do we uh go and solve real
problems it's more so like i got this
contract it lasts for a long time it's
providing this great uh kind of
financial benefit is that like a fair
characterization or am i being too kind
of tough on uh analyzing like the
existing part of the system so i think
there's some businesses where the owner
is kind of absent and you know it is
like that you know they've got a bunch
of northrop grumman contracts and it's
been rolling for 20 years and they're
never going to have to reshaw that
business like it's always going to stay
there it's a very sticky revenue base i
think a lot of owner operator machinists
do have a really tough time like like
manufacturing is hard
um these people are like incredible at
what they do as owner operators um
but yeah there are some of these legacy
companies where
there's probably not a lot of work
involved you know the employers have
been there for 20 years the contracts
have been there for 30 years don't worry
about it and there is a definitely
especially in defense there's a huge
subset of businesses like that where
yeah they've been around for 20 years
they're going to be around for 20 years
and it's a pretty easy gig yeah so when
we start to think about what you're
actually building right so there's a
fragmented uh kind of i'll call it an
analog system even though uh there's
little software mostly analog
what what are you building like how does
this work from like a software and
you're laughing because i know people
are asking interest right yeah but
it's uh from what i understand it's a
software manufacturing and supply chain
software we're building highly automated
factories basically okay whether do you
have physical factories yeah we have two
in the moment in l.a okay explain more
so basically from a customer's
perspective what they want is what
they're getting is hey they say hey i
want a bunch of rocket engine parts and
they get they're getting them in 10 to
12 weeks 30 to 40 of those orders end up
several weeks later have quality issues
and then the customer service is
incredibly poor like i call pomp's
machine shop and say like hey you
promised me this in six weeks i haven't
heard anything and it's week five like
what's going on and then you like hang
up the phone or you don't even know
because you don't have the capacity of
your own factory right so these big
rocket manufacturers they're literally
calling like mom and pop shops to get
some of these parts right now oh yeah
yeah completely so the entire advanced
manufacturing like supply chain in the
us is basically resting on this this
house of cards of small machine shops
which did an incredible job for the
country in the first space race in the
cold war but are now just no longer
keeping up with the demands of all these
advanced companies and how much of this
is um there's challenges with like
quality so like i order five parts from
five different people and they make all
come in different you know measurements
or quality or stuff like that versus
it's just like i need the five parts and
like i don't know if i get them today or
in a week both both so like what can
happen is you might be like an aerospace
engineer that's trying to get a
satellite design done by the first of
june right and you've got an assembly
team so you need the parts a couple of
weeks beforehand so you've sent out all
these contracts for different parts and
they've all said yeah we'll definitely
get them to you by like you know the
first of may um so firstly like half of
those will end up in the third week of
may so now your assembly team is
panicking which is like terrible right
you're like trying to run a mcdonald's
and you're like your paddy's supplier i
just can't really tell you whether the
paddies are coming on thursday or like
next monday how can you possibly surf
customers it's completely insane on the
quality side
the tolerances of parts that this supply
base and that we are making are down to
like micron you know surface profile
tolerances right so you might look at
like a satellite housing that looks you
know the size of a laptop and across
that entire surface the position of a
hole has to correlate to a position of
another hole within a couple of microns
so you're dealing with tolerances where
like
um we climate control our factory down
to like one degree fahrenheit variance
in machining if the sun shines on a
machine at the start of the day the
parts will come off completely different
to the end of the day when the sun is
not shining through the window because
you don't you're down to so incredibly
close like tolerance for the quality
side that even like the heat thermal
expansion properties of like the
aluminum part can like literally change
based on you know a couple of degrees in
weather so it's really hard to do
properly but yeah that sounds really
hard yeah so you're in this you're in
this pressure cooker situation where
like you know you're screaming at me
saying i'm trying to make the satellite
i'm trying to get you parts and maybe on
the day that we're meant to ship them i
call you i'm like hey two of them are
out of tolerance like can you can you
just accept them anyway and use them
like it's complete it's completely
insane one of the things that i read too
when you guys announced your fundraising
was that you said that you guys were
hiring people from all over basically i
think the companies you had mentioned
were like chick-fil-a and walmart
and you have them basically down to make
the they're able to make the parts
within 30 days how are you able to do
that so this is where the software comes
in so
basically from every part of the process
from you know coding a job to scheduling
the factory and managing capacity and
then doing all the workflow of like you
know how do you spit out all the tasks
through the machines or humans as as
part of this manufacturing process
a lot of it is digital because you
actually got to program the machine to
like cut these parts you know it's
custom geometry every single time and
then operating the machines can be
incredibly difficult where you're using
firstly these things are like two
million dollars each they're incredibly
like you know they're two tons you know
they're moving around 2000 pounds of
steel at like you know 1.2 g's but still
hitting like sub micron tolerances
they're incredible things right and
usually what happens is you've got a
custom piece of software that the
manufacturer has written where you have
to learn this obscure code base or learn
this obscure user interface to just run
one of the machines
um
so what we've done with all of our
software is basically at each step of
this process including running the
machines automated 80 or 90 of it
and then wrapped our own user interfaces
around the 10 that's still very hard for
a computer to do there are some
computation stuff that you know a human
can select the right outcome in five
minutes but you might take three phds
for five years to automate that bit we
wrap it around a way simply user
interface so that an operator from say
chick-fil-a can be running one of these
five-axis machines in 30 days because
they're not starting from scratch and
learning how to set a tool or figure out
what this crazy ui is or get into the
depth of this machine to figure out how
to even turn it on most of that's
automated and the tasks they have to do
are in our software that we've basically
connected everything together so that
you know you can set someone in front of
a machine it's not you know it's not
super intimidating you know our software
looks more like you know instagram or
something like that and that's how we're
doing the whole thing yeah so when you
think about this uh are you starting
with a specific type of part to okay so
like i assume
focus is really important here get it
right and then you kind of expand what
are the parts that you're starting with
so anything uh in aluminum within a
bounding box of about you know 28 inches
cubed and the reason for that is in in
aerospace you've basically got like
aluminum steel titanium and ink canals
and you know ink nails might go on a
rocket engine because it you know it can
get really hot and doesn't warp aluminum
is like great for satellites or like
rocket housings and stuff so basically
we built a factory that as long as it's
aluminum you know within a certain
bounding box you can throw a cad file at
us and we'll spit out a part you know
10x faster than anybody else basically
and is this like the equivalent of 3d
printing but with uh different materials
or like how are you doing it yeah so
this is cnc machining which is
subtractive so additive is you know you
build up deposition of material
subtractive as you cut it away and for
aerospace and defense and semiconductor
the the quality and the tolerance is so
tight that 3d printing technology is
five to six years away from having tight
enough tolerances to be able to make
aerospace parts so if you wanted to
print something 3d printed for
automotive where like it might be within
a couple of foul quality because the car
needs to be accurate but not like super
accurate but if you're making something
for you know a human space flight
program like it has to be super accurate
otherwise like people can die and the 3d
printing technology just isn't there
yeah so the subtractive model is much
better okay now another question i have
is uh there's varda there's a bunch of
these companies that now um i think
the invention of the reusable rocket
right and the ability to kind of drop
the cost of uh rocketry uh is gonna lead
to you know the explosion of space let's
call it 100 uh are you guys targeting
the vardas of the world or are you
targeting the like lockheed you know
what i would think of like the legacy uh
people who have been participating in in
kind of this space enabled world like
who who is the better customer like
somebody who's technology enabled or
somebody who has no technology at all
really so the short answer is both okay
but for this year we're just doing what
i would call like new commercial space
and defense okay which is companies like
vader and deleon uh deleon who
co-founded vada led uh co-led our seed
round with with lux capital um this is
almost a year ago now
so don't tell us that we're gonna get
mad at delia for not calling us
i was just saying i was checking my
phone i didn't see a call
like where's the alpha yeah like all
right
and and then he's like yo if i should
bring chris on the podcast
strike two deleon yeah it could have
been 12 months ago
let's do this in reverse next time
um so but those types of companies are
the ones you space new space first
because it's your classic startup
dynamic of like hey if you're a stripe
you want to sell to y combinator
startups because they'll adopt you
quickly right yes and they understand
the value you probably do less like
convincing them yeah yeah and then um
what i would call the larger primes or
the largest based companies no we're
engaging with them as well the response
for since we announced the fundraise
been absolutely incredible it's just
that their internal processes might take
six months to onboard us whereas you
know a new space company might take
three weeks so we're working with both
of them in parallel but we don't expect
any revenue to kick in from the like
larger legacy companies or no they're
not even legacy companies they're just
massive massive more bureaucratic yeah
yeah yeah um
or they're working on government
programs so you know their processes
have to be supe way way way tighter than
someone who's just putting a commercial
satellite up how uh how long does it
take to build a factory
ah so we we retrofitted an existing
factory within i think like 47 days
which is
like 9 to 12 months faster than anybody
else the new factory that is coming
online which is about 100 000 square
foot just you know in torrance in la
will come online i think roughly july
1st and that took us from signing the
lease i think it'll be like five months
um because
it's super fast because it's it's like
rolling out a starbucks franchise or
rolling out an amazon logistics center
like for amazon to scale one of the
things they have to get really good at
and they do get really good at is
rolling out logistics centers super
super fast so you know you acquire a
site and within 60 days there's 100
people that you know pick back in books
or whatever we basically have to do the
same thing this is why this is such a
painful business to execute is because
if we want to hit like a exponential
growth curve like your average sas
company we have to have a great product
we have to be great at selling it we
have to be credit onboarding customers
we also have to learn how to scale
factories as fast as [ __ ] like you
can roll out starbucks franchises or you
can roll out amazon logistics centers so
part of what part of our like
competitive advantage is like you know
give us another six months and we'll
launch like two factories and start
building the third one and then skip
ahead a year and like good luck finding
another team who can like build
factories in a couple of months you know
yeah and so when you think about
building the factory how much of it's
like uh the i'll call the organization
of the machinery versus there's other
things you have to do like what's the
slowest part of it right now i mean i'll
give you an example we nearly lost
schedule because you can barely find any
concrete or cement in the country right
now just because of supply chain issues
that's part of the ukraine russia
conflict but also you're going to space
and you can't find [ __ ] concrete yes
literally
yeah so these machines are so accurate
that we actually have to retrofit the
factories with 18-inch concrete
foundations yeah vibration isolation
pads so if a truck drives past yeah they
don't they don't move right yep and your
usual out of the box factory that you
you know acquire from commercial real
estate maybe has like four to six inches
right so we have to like literally rip
up the floors and like do it again we're
putting uh hvac in the entire factory so
that at any point in the factory it's
climate controlled within a couple of
degrees fahrenheit so that's a hundred
thousand square foot factory yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like a lot of it's like a
lot of energy and it's a lot of uh it's
a lot of hvac it's really expensive but
like you know a lot of the hvac material
is made out of like you know aluminum
tubing or steel tubing and you just like
can't get the raw materials at the
moment so if we're just fighting this
inflationary effect of both the conflict
and the fed all the time because it's
causing these massive supply chain
shocks so part of what we do is yeah we
have to retrofit the buildings to be
um to land the machines and then you
know it's effectively just plugging
everything in and setting everything up
and commissioning the machines so yeah
yeah inflate inflation's only eight and
a half percent don't worry about it um
yeah hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time